chemistry phd here with some skincare  tips you don't need an oil cleanser to  remove sunscreen it depends on how  strong your regular cleanser is how  resistant your sunscreen is and really  what you prefer using in your routine if  you think about washing greasy dishes  you don't need oil to wash the grease  off your dishes you just use dishwashing  liquid same idea you don't need oil to  wash your face dishwashing liquid and  regular cleansers both have ingredients  called surfactants their structures have  an oily part so the whole oil dissolves  oil thing still works because the  surfactant basically acts like an oil